[Music]
a cryptonian scientist the Days of Our
Lives inspiration and a young Barry
Allen while these DC actors are no
longer with us their performances will
live on when it comes to Daily newspaper
editors who unknowingly work alongside
world famous crime Fighters J Jonah Jam
of The Daily Bugle tends to overshadow
Perry white to the Daily Planet that's
got nothing to do with either of their
journalistic abilities of course JJ's
just a larger than life personality and
essentially one of the villains in many
Spider-Man stories on the other hand
Perry white such a DieHard print media
professional and Advocate he's been
played by many more actors than JJ who's
principally associated with the version
played by JK Simmons in Sam ry's
Spider-Man trilogy he is in my 40 years
in this business the fastest typist I've
ever seen although he's not the only
live-action Perry white the Superman
world's answer to Simmons is probably
Jackie Cooper who corrects Clark Kent's
spelling errors in Superman Superman 2
Superman 3 and Superman 4 the Quest for
Peace despite a major role in one of the
most successful film franchises of the
1980s Cooper arguably never surpassed
his career Zenith at the age of n when
he became the Young youngest actor Ever
nominated for best actor at the 1931
Academy Awards but you could also argue
that acting steadily in film and TV from
the early 30s up until 1990 is a bigger
accomplishment than any single role or
nomination Cooper died in 2011 at the
age of 88 easy Miss I've got you you
you've got me who's got you the
tragically short nature of Christopher
Reeves life has been widely publicized
but when Margot K passed away in May
2018 at 69 we still felt it was too soon
arguably no major DC character has
evolved and improved over the decades
more than Lois Lane once a bumbling
airheaded Kutz in constant need of
rescue today's Lois is a world famous
journalist and media personality
generally depicted as a savier operator
than a Kryptonian husband now and again
Lois does her own fair share of
metahuman adjacent crime fighting albe
it's in a far less conspicuous capacity
than her spouse or most of his
colleagues ker appears in all the
Superman films co-starring Ree and we
need only focus on Superman 2 for
examples of ker helping undo the
perception of Lois as a mere Damelin in
distress K Lois is not oblivious she's
occasionally Reckless but only when
journalistic truth is at stake unlike
previous iterations K Lois figures out
that her bumbling coworker and the
literal benevolent space god that
follows her around happen to be the same
guy setting a precedent for future Lois
Lanes who don't buy that silly glasses
disguise either the quartet of Batman
film starting with Batman and ending
with Batman and Robin can feel a little
disjointed beginning in a gloomy quirky
iteration of Gotham directed by Tim
Burton and ending with a candy coated
cartoon fever dream imagined by Joel
Schumacher the series foregoes a solid
sense of consistency except when it
comes to Alfred well I think I've
embarrassed him for long enough veteran
British actor Michael G holds down the
fort as Batman's congenial Butler Alfred
pennyworth in all four films including
Batman Returns in Batman Forever as is
more or less customary for Alfred gos
version functions as a voice of reason
throughout Batman's Adventures while
he's more than happy to help Bruce and a
sidekick Sav the world he'd sleep a
little easier if his surrogate son could
just get set up with a nice girl and
hang up the back costume G's TV filmm
and theater career started in the mid1
1940s so to say that there was a little
more to his career than his run as
Alfred would be a substantial
understatement golf passed away in March
2011 at '94 roughly a mere 6 years short
of triple
digits with all due respect to Jeep snon
who portrayed the venomed up villain in
Batman and Robin it's probably fair to
say audiences prefer the version of Bane
played by Tom Hardy and The Dark Knight
Rises but we don't say that to diminish
Swenson's acting abilities after all the
problems with Batman and Robin extend
far beyond on its presentation of Bane
swensson caught more than one
significant crummy break during his
essentially successful career in which
he spent time in multiple sections of
the entertainment industry his tenure
with the once prominent but currently
defunct world championship wrestling
might have lasted longer had the
organization's creative Department come
up with a less aggressively offensive
and anti-semitic name for him than the
final solution Swenson died shortly
after the release of Batman and Robin in
1997 at the age of 40 you might not
immediately recognize his name but we
assure you you know William Hopkins he's
mentioned here specifically for his turn
as a corrupt lieutenant eert and Batman
and to a lesser extent for the solemn
duty of performing in Superman 4 the
Quest for Peace in the guise of Harry
howler but the character actor had a few
more notable credits for instance in
Star Wars his character named Porkins
Pilots a ship called an X-Wing and
attacks a moon-sized space station known
as the Death Star the known for minor
roles in Hollywood his reputation in
London's theater scene was a different
story his obituary cites his ongoing
starring role in the play Hitchcock
blonde as his career's greatest Triumph
but for actors with as many projects
under their belts as hootkins what
they're known for becomes a matter of
subjectivity in some respects he died in
2005 at the age of 57 a fixture of
televised comedy since her late 80s
stint on Saturday Night Live with
subsequent recurring roles on The
Simpsons and Third Rock From the Sun Jen
hooks also appeared in Batman Returns
evil businessman Max Shrek hires her
character to explain stuff to
presumptive Gotham City mayoral
candidate the penguin like why voters
prefer fingers to Flippers the Tim
Burton directed sequel to Batman man is
not Hook's only DC related credit she
also plays a woman who claims to be
raising Superman's love child on cbst
TV's Superman 50th Anniversary Special A
light-hearted Slice of Superman ephemera
books passed away in 2014 at 57 years
old Danny DeVito's penguin recruits a
wide variety of minions for his crime
spree in Batman Returns although they
don't all have obvious utilitarian value
if you're putting together a gang to
inflict the maximum amount of violence
in Mayhem then why bother signing up an
organ grinder Penguins thinking maybe
too sophisticated for us to comprehend
so we just have to take it on faith that
the musical accompaniment produced by
Vincent cavelli's character plus the
amusement provided by his dancing monkey
was essential to Oswald cobblepot's
diabolical machinations beyond the
confines of Batman Returns ski ofi
carved out a niche is one of the great
character actors of his ERA with turns
in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest Pas
Times at Ridgemont High and ghost xfiles
fans May recognize him from the cult
favorite episode humbug and which he
guest stars along with Michael J
Anderson and Jim Rose founder of the
circus of the same name ski Elli passed
away in 2005 at the age of
57 a high-ranking staff member at Arkham
Asylum who happens to be named Dr Burton
is not even close to the goofiest thing
in Batman Forever but creating a tossa
away character for purposes of
delivering a good nature dig at director
Tim Burton who oversaw the previous two
Batman films feels like a cheeky move on
the part of director Joel Schumacher we
suppose it would be disappointing for
Rene oena if his only major acting work
consisted of a brief scene as a gag
character at the end of a lesser Batman
movie but that's not even close to the
case though he contributed a physical or
vocal performance to an insane amount of
TV shows including numerous DC and
Marvel animated projects obar genois is
most widely remembered as Odo on Star
Trek Deep Space 9 he died in 2019 not
long after the release of the critically
beloved first cow one of his last movies
at the age of
79 Sam Lane doesn't always get to live
up to his full potential in liveaction
Superman iterations so in a way it's
unfortunate that we must gloss over har
prell's role as Lois Lane's estranged
father on Lois and Clark to discuss his
more significant work the writer
director team of Joel and Ethan Cohen
put themselves on Hollywood's radar with
Blood Simple they didn't demonstrate
their full Mastery of smalltown murder
drama until Fargo used car salesman
Jerry lundgard hires a pair of Hitman
for an elaborate kidnapping scheme
designed to scam his father-in-law the
situation collapses into a tragic bloody
shambles the American Film Institute
once ranked Fargo is one of the top 100
films of all time and it would be a
completely different movie without the
veteran prell's Conjuring of Wade
gustofson Lund guard's overbearing
father-in-law and would be mark presel
died in 2009 at the age of
75 here's where we confess that calling
screen comedy Legend Fred Willard a DC
actor is insanely reductive and the same
statement applies to a handful of
entries on this list Willard's oblivious
game show host like Persona has added to
the satirical irony of film such as this
is spinal tap Best in Show and Anchor
Man Willard also played the president of
the United States on Lois and Clark as
well as the deputy mayor of metropolis
in the Superman 50th Anniversary Special
somehow in Superman related media
Willard kept finding his way into
positions of political power we' chock
that up to coincidence if we believed in
coincidence Willard passed away in May
2020 at the age of
86 the single season TV show The Flash
from the early 90s never managed to
amass the retro cool credibility of
Batman from 1966 or Wonder Woman from
1975 there are probably multiple reasons
for that but a glance at the show's
intro music and opening credits
indicates that somebody in charge wanted
very much for the flash of network
television to be the Batman of Tim
Burton films CBS didn't have the budget
and Barry Allen didn't have the an to
fulfill that expectation that's kind of
unfortunate for Biff mayard as he
appears in 17 out of the 22 episode run
of the flash he was able to have a more
than respectable career in Legacy
outside of his time as officer Michael
Murphy though mayard shows up in both
entries of the cult Sci-Fi series
transfers and acted on a score of
television shows throughout the 80s and
90s he died in 2014 at the age of 71
cyborg the Aquaman where the hell are
you fish cyborg has enjoyed something of
a liveaction Revival as of late as
played by Ray fiser he got a heck of a
lot more screen time in the recently
released Zack Snider's Justice League
than he did in the original edits while
an iteration played by Javan Wade has
regularly appeared on Max's Doom Patrol
series but back in the 2000s when Studio
Executives falsely assumed television
could only handle one DC based Prime
Time drama at a time Lee Thompson Young
was mass media's one and only Flesh and
Blood Victor Stone though he only drops
by for three hourlong adventures with
Clark Kent on Smallville Young's version
of stone gets to be a co-founder of the
Justice League alongside green arrow
that means that the onetime Friday night
and the famous jet Jackson star
definitely set some of the groundwork
for Ray Fischer's tenure with a
character young unfortunately died from
suicide in 2013 at the age of
29 perhaps you already know that Ruder
Hower certainly one of the most
recognized character actors in sci-fi
fantasy died in July 2019 and maybe you
also already know that he played the
nefarious Wayne Enterprises executive
credited only as Earl in Batman Begins
while we left Heath Ledger and
Christopher reev off this list because
they're both highly publicized celebrity
deaths their careers are both also
closely associated with their tenures as
major DC characters how on the other
hand is probably too famous for the
relatively minor part he plays in Batman
Begins we happen to know it's possible
to watch multiple screenings of Batman
Begins and still not notice the classic
Blade Runner antagonist Roy baddy
reassuring Bruce Wayne that he's got the
best interest of the Wayne Legacy at
heart though Earl isn't a major part of
Batman Begins The Dark Knight wouldn't
be the same movie if Bruce Wayne had not
overcome a sleazy corporate lanter
climber in the first part of the trilogy
there go we can say there are two
indispensable sci-fi fantasy action
franchises that would not be the same
today without Howard Bruce you're
supposed to be dead sorry to disappoint
Heath Ledger once in a generation
performance as the Joker tends to gobble
up a huge chunk of the discourse when it
comes to the Dark Knight and rightfully
so but it's unfortunate how matters
related to The Joker overshadow so many
other components of Christopher Nolan's
tour to force Tom tiny liser Jr only
spends a few moments on screen but is
the tattooed inmate who protects a ship
full of civilians by tossing the switch
to one of the Joker's bombs into the
ocean he certainly makes those few
moments count List's poignant appearance
in the dark night isn't necessarily his
most impressive career accomplishment
back in the 80s liser went by the Alias
of Zeus and Main evented the 1989
SummerSlam pay-per-view card teaming
with Macho Man Randy Savage against a
tandem of Hulk Hogan and Brutus The
Barber Beefcake the rest of List's
resume includes featured roles in Friday
The Fifth Element and Jackie Brown liser
passed away in December 2020 at the age
of 62 Logan Williams appears as young
Barry Allen in flashback in time travel
sequences during the first two seasons
of CWS The Flash he also had a recurring
role on the Hallmark Channel period
drama When Calls the Heart and landed
his first role in the Hallmark movie the
color of rain at the age of 10 he died
in 2020 at 16 years old after a
three-year battle with opioid addiction
his mother Marley said at the time his
death is not going to be in vain he's
going to help a lot of people down the
road according to the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention nearly
69,000 people in the US died from
overdosing on synthetic opioids in 2020
sad Logan Williams was one of those
statistics far too early into his life
and what should have been a long and
promising career can't you remember
anything I Remember the
Alamo the Paul ruin place in pop culture
history was assured by his most beloved
creation PeeWee Herman the actor
comedian also played a variety of other
roles some of which trucked into not so
funny territory case in point Batman
Returns which reunited ruin with
peewee's big adventure director Tim
Burton he played Tucker cobblepot a
Gotham City district attorney who is
horrified to discover that his infant
son Oswald is physically disfigured
cobblepot abandons his child who
subsequently raised by Emperor penguins
at the old Gotham City Zoo and later
becomes the Monstrous penguin Ruben
played a drug dealer in blow the
Restless ghost of a suicide victim in
life during wartime and the strange Mr
Vargas in five episodes of The Blacklist
he also played Elijah vanal a more
sympathetic version of The Penguin's
father on three episodes of Gotham he
voiced several DC characters including
batm might and The Riddler on Batman man
the Brave and the Bold and the Robot
Chicken DC Comics specials respectively
Reuben's death from cancer at the age of
70 on July 30th 2023 was mourned by fans
and collaborators alike though numerous
actors have attempted to put their stamp
on the physicality of Batman one
performer largely defin the dark
Knight's voice for more than three
decades voice actor Kevin Conroy debuted
as Batman in Bruce Tim and Eric romsky
emmy-winning Batman the Animated Series
in 1992 and continued to voice the
character in dozens and dozens of
projects including other DC anim
Universe series feature films and video
games Conroy also played the Earth 99
variant of Bruce Wayne on the CW's
liveaction arse crossover event crisis
on infinite Earths Conroy who studied
acting at juliard began his career in
theater and amassed a sizable number of
liveaction television credits including
recurring roles on Dynasty and Tour of
Duty in addition to his many turns as
Batman Conroy also lent his distinctive
voice to such animated series as the
adventure Brothers Ben 10 Alien Force
and He-Man and the Masters of the
Universe in 2022 Conroy pen fin ing
Batman which detailed how his own
troubled childhood and experiences as a
gay man informed his betrayal of Batman
for DC Pride
2022 conoy died of intestinal cancer at
the age of 66 on November 10th 2022 his
final performance as Batman will be
featured in Rock Steady game Suicide
Squad kill the Justice League in
2024 though created by Paul Dei and
Bruce Tim the DC anti-hero Harley Quinn
also owes adbt actress Arlene sorin for
her iconic look voice and attitude deie
who knew sorin from college saw
compilation re of her appearances as The
Eccentric Kia B Jones on days of her
lives which included a scene in which
she was dressed as a Jester the scene
inspired deie and Tim to create Harley
Quinn a wise cracking henchwoman in foil
for the Joker on Batman the Animated
Series and they tap sorin to voice the
character she went on to play Quinn in
five other animated series and numerous
video games fine I'll show you you'll be
sorry I'll pull a Big Heist and I'll be
laughing at you haha you he laughing she
logged more than 400 appearances on the
days of lives as well as recurring in
guest shots on series like duet and
Frasier additionally Soren wrote
episodes of tiny tune Adventures created
the short-lived sitcom fired up and
co-produced a 2010 documentary on
Pakistani prime minister Ben airbo sorin
died of complications from pneumonia and
multiple sclerosis on August 24th
2023 from the mid1 1960s until Tim
Burton's 1989 film Batman Adam West was
the on-screen face and voice of Batman
for a generation of audiences Wes played
both the Caped Crusader and his dashing
Al ego Bruce Wayne on ABC's Batman
series from 1966 to 1968 but was unable
to Parlay that show's brief but meteoric
Fame into a more substantial acting
career like George Reeves and many other
actors who played superheroes Wes found
Batman to be a blessing and a curse it
elevated him to start on but also became
a glass ceiling through which he was
unable to break for decades perseverance
and a willingness to spoof his screen
Persona led to Wes Revival as a comic
actor and voice performer in the 1990s
and 2000s he appeared often as a smug
version of him self in series like King
of Queens as well as films like drop
dead gorgeous and he voiced numerous
characters in animated series including
the deranged mayor on Family Guy oh what
don't you have in that belt patience for
Harley Quinn hoodlums like yourself he
also reted with Batman co-star Bert Ward
to reprise their roles in animated form
in two features including Batman Return
of the Caped Crusaders in 2016 West
death from leukemia at the age of 88 on
June 9th 2017 was commemorated by the
city of Los Angeles which shown the bat
signal on City Hall on June 15th of that
year season 1 episode 6 of Lucifer
titled favorite son introduced viewers
to Hank cutter president of the Los
Diablos motorcycle club whom Lucifer and
Khloe suspect as the chief culprit
behind the theft of a shipping container
belonging to the Prince of Darkness from
a warehouse Hank proves to be anything
but the typical biker Captain though he
looks tough as Nails What Hank really
wants to do is start his own clothing
line he doesn't even like riding his
bike Tom seore was in the midst of a
comeback when he appeared as Hank cutter
on Lucifer a substance abuse problem and
other personal issues had caused the
Golden Globe and Screen Actor Guild
nominee to fall far from his status as a
popular character actor in films like
Saving Private Ryan heat and
natural-born Killers after Stinson rehab
in jail in the 2010 seore began to
rebuild his screen career largely
through recurring roles on Hawaii 5 the
Red Road and the 2017 Revival of Twin
Peaks however seore was hospitalized
After experiencing a brain aneurism and
stroke at his home in Los Angeles on
February 18th 2023 doctors informed his
family on February 27th that there was
no chance of recovery and his family
made an endof life decision for the
61-year-old actor he died on March 3rd
20123 Warner Brothers 2010 feature
version of DC's weird Western Title
Jonah Hex was an unmitigated disaster
upon release you can't place the blame
on its cast however including Lance reic
the John Wick star plays a general store
owner who also supplies hex with his
heavy duty Weaponry a onetime music
student who released an album of
contemporary jazz in 2010 reic began
acting in the late 1990s and earned his
first Big Break as Baltimore Police
lieutenant and later commissioner Cedric
Daniels on The Wire the critical success
of that series LED to steady work for
reic and character roles often as
authority figures on series like lost
Bosch and Resident Evil and in films
like the John Wick tetrology which cast
him as the Continentals concierge as
well as White House Down and Godzilla
versus Kong reic died of heart disease
at the age of 60 at his home and Los
Angeles California on March 17th
2023 I love you son stop British actor
Julian Sans played a crucial figure in
Superman's Mythos in Seasons 9 and 10 of
Smallville Sans played Jor L the
Kryptonian scientist who sends his son
Cal L to Earth to avoid their planet's
destruction he also transfers his brain
waves into his son spacecraft providing
him with the superior intellect to
become Superman Smallville was not
sans's only forray into DC projects He
also played Dr Gerald crane father of
the Scarecrow on Gotham Sans Rose to
Fame in the 1980s playing diametrically
opposite romantic characters Helena
bottom Carter's freethinking love
interest in a room of a view and a
haunted Percy Bish Shelly in Gothic he
soon proved toep at a wide array of
characters from a malevolent spellcaster
in Warlock and a dashing entomologist in
Arachnophobia to a vicious pimp in
Leaving Las Vegas no part proofed two
off beat for Sans he was a centipede in
human form in David cronenberg's Naked
Lunch the title character and Dario
argento's The Phantom of the Opera and
even the voice of a cat in bobbleheads
the movie between these assignments were
numerous television roles stage work and
voice for video games an avid hiker Sans
disappeared in California San Gabriel
mountains in January 2023 human remains
found in the area on June 24th 2023 were
positively identified as a 65-year-old
actor whose cause of death remains
undetermined